[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got new
details on flashback scenes during
Avengers 4 thanks to one of the actors
talking about stuff on a podcast when he
probably shouldn't have said anything
but I'll explain what's going on there's
a new round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Marvel
related comment on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this recently
frank grillo went on the UFC unfiltered
podcast and they were talking mostly
about UFC related stuff but they started
talking about the Avengers movies he
said he himself doesn't spend a lot of
time watching that like he doesn't watch
anything fantasy or sci-fi or anything
like that
so he hasn't even seen the latest
infinity war movie but when they asked
him if they're gonna see his character
again because they did spend a lot of
time talking about Winter Soldier and
crossbones character he was being a
total bro so I'll just read his quote
here verbatim he says he makes an
appearance in the next Avengers movie
but because he's dead it's a flashback
I'm allowed to say whatever I want
because I'm never doing another Marvel
movie
would you say he remembered you I was
there he got all weepy about it until
they put his brain back in a blender he
wanted you to know something he said to
me please tell Rodgers when you gotta go
you gotta go
he joked that it's not so much because
crossbones is dead but because he refers
to himself as being like a hundred and
seventeen years old so we're getting a
Captain America crossbones specific
flashback there are really only two
scenes that that could be him during
Captain America Civil War and then him
during Winter Soldier the Captain
America Civil War moment was a little
bit more comic book II because he has
that full gear on and they just totally
throw down it was sort of the beginning
of the end of the Avengers and then
breaking up because of what Scarlet
Witch accidentally did killing all those
people when she was trying to save some
other ones and because of things that
Chris Evans has been talking about in
real life lately which I'll address
later it's also that moment that he has
where he says Bucky wanted you to know
when you gotta go you gotta go so it's a
big moment about his history with Bucky
with crossbones with the Avengers
breaking up and about quote-unquote
going out in a metaphorical way the
events of Winter Soldier are also
particularly important for Captain
America just because of how he toppled
Hydra during that movie so it was such a
big event in his history before we get
started does anyone want to get out
so it just depends on what they're using
the flashback to provide context for in
the future they're only a couple of
reasons why you do flashbacks you
typically do those in finales to show
how much a character has grown like look
at what they used to be like look at
this big event in their life and how it
changed them in what they seem like
today then also to remind the audience
about some critical piece of information
that informs what's happening with the
problem they're trying to solve in
present day so I think because Avengers
4 is all about the Avengers coming
together as a true team is probably
going to be a civil war beginning of the
end like this was the event that slowly
led to our downfall during civil war as
we slowly come back together with the
help of Captain Marvel and take down a
nose and fix the universe so I mean it's
kind of a bummer when Avengers poor
picks up but it's meant to be a more
hopeful ending than the end of infinity
war in the fact that Frank Grillo does
that funny I'm getting too old for this
ship by saying he's a hundred and
seventeen years old and he doesn't have
the energy to do Marvel stuff anymore
makes it seem like it's a relatively
action-heavy scene where he's wearing a
lot of gear which would be more of a
civil war moment but he didn't say what
kind of a costume he was wearing or
anything like that but just the sheer
fact that they're doing a flashback with
his character is important because while
we had seen all these behind the scenes
picks of the original Battle of New York
with the Avengers in their classic
costumes we didn't know if it would be a
flashback heavy movie but like I said
usually that's what you do in a big
finale and this is sort of like the last
really big Avengers movie for the phase
1 Avengers maybe not the last Marvel
movie that they ever appear in but this
is sort of their avengers retirement
party as they sort of ushered in all the
new heroes like Captain Marvel black
panther or spider-man and the old ones
sort of transitioned to background roles
like Black Widow will continue on in her
movie but that's set during the past
Ironman keeps talking about retirement
Chris Evans openly spoke about how he's
not going to do any more Marvel movies
and sort of tweeting stuff making people
think that he was going to die I don't
know it's a you don't want to give
anything away and and I should clarify
that you know
I know I did tweet something that made a
lot of people think that it was in some
way spoiler and I just I should clarify
that regardless regardless of how
Avengers four ends I would have tweeted
the exact same thing you know it really
was you know that last day of filming
was a very emotional day and it was the
culmination of almost 10 years of
filming and 22 movies this unbelievable
tapestry and you know you you you feel a
lot more emotions than I think even I
thought I'd feel and you know I felt it
was appropriate to share the gratitude I
know it had a ripple effect but I am
neither confirming nor denying anything
but you can kind of see as a
storytelling device how they're hitting
all the biggest moments that they have
together like during age of Ultron when
they all went around after they found
out what Tony had done with Ultron
accidentally creating him with the help
of the mind Jim his quotes during that
are really important that up there
that's endgame so it's them talking
about big-picture stuff and that's what
Avengers 4 is it's the culmination of
all the big-picture stuff
unfortunately the Russos Dee confirmed
that the title of Avengers 4 has never
actually been spoken in dialogue in any
of the movies that they know of
so Ironman sang the words end game
during that speech mean that that's not
going to be the title of the movie it
was one of my early theories there been
a couple others that have been knocked
off the list there's even this clip that
someone cleaned up of Mark Ruffalo sang
the last Avenger the audio is a little
weird but he really does say the last
Avenger the reason why I'm still a
little bit skeptical even after that is
because his whole appearance there was
meant to be a bit of a troll to get
people to watch thinking that he would
spoil something from Avengers 4 so that
he could then turn around and tell them
to go out and vote in the upcoming
election happening in the United States
so I will be very surprised if the title
is the last Avenger whatever the title
is going to be I still think that it's
going to be two words and Avengers will
come first so it'll be Avengers subtitle
and if Marvel doesn't officially release
that by mid-november in the next couple
of weeks that I'd be willing to bet that
they're just gonna save it for a title
card in the trailer at the end
of November when they dropped that I've
already done a couple videos about when
that's probably going to drop it'll
probably be on Good Morning America
we'll get some more specific information
when we get closer but let me know in
the comments what do you think about
this frank grillo interview and which
scene do you think that they did a
flashback to is it gonna be Captain
America Civil War full comic-book
crossbones because that's more of an
Avengers moment or do you think it's
gonna be a Winter Soldier flashback
right now I'm just leaning towards more
Avengers stuff with him in full
comic-book gear but we'll find out more
pretty soon leave all your Marvel video
requests in the comments below
congratulations Ryan brocco Monty you're
the giveaway winner for my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for that
teaser about Iron Man's new armor during
Avengers 4 and click here to watch Chris
Evans talk about his Avengers force
scenes
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]